hello everybody Markab I here with the
first fan mail video opening ceremony of
markiplier is greatness I really got to
work in the name I don't know what to
call this but anyway I've got my fan
mail here in the responsibly reduce it's
been tons and tons and tons and tons of
stuff that had piled up I mean look at
this gigantic stack of mail here I'm
gonna try to avoid putting you know
addresses up on the screen here but this
is another part of the stack just giant
piles of it I got big boxes down here
I'm not gonna be able to open and read
all of them but I've picked a few I've
already opened all the letters and read
all the letters so thank you guys for
everything you said there have been so
many kind words and stories and I just
kind of picked a few at random I don't
really want to like specialize but I
just grabbed some and some are opened
and some of the bigger ones I want to
make sure that they you know you know
people see them on camera like these
boxes I don't know what's in the boxes
but we're gonna find out together so
let's get started we got a lot to get
through so let's go right now this is
from who's this from I don't know but
there's fan art here I can't I can't
grow a glorious mustache stop reminding
me okay and then there's a Wharf staff
down there this is haha new well thank
you so much who is this who is this
let's see this is from oh goodness or
Ariel I think so yeah Ariel that's right
this will sound sappy but you're one of
my heroes the other two are eddsworld
and Billie Joe Armstrong for years I've
been bullied about being weird saying
that I'm worthless when I go into high
school I tried to act like all the
others needless to say it made me
unhappy then I stumbled upon your
channel when I watched you and yamimash
play Slendy Toby's after just a few
videos I fell in love with you
metaphorically speaking and your style
soon after I started being myself again
I can tell anyone who I am and not be
ashamed and I can shout it to everyone
my name is Ariel I have I'm a tomboy who
loves anime and cartoons I'm a nerd that
doesn't do drugs and is still a virgin
I'm probably shouldn't read that out
loud
well you're shouting it from the
rooftops so we're
which I'm quite proud of by the way so
yeah you're shouting it from the
rooftops you have taught me things how
to laugh how to have fun but most
importantly you taught me that being
weird is awesome it's not a crack at me
I'm not weird I'm normal but thank you
guys thank you so much Arielle thank you
really truly now I'm glad to hear this
end I hope you don't mind me reading
these like some of them that I read told
me explicitly not to read them on camera
so I will avoid reading any of those
thank you so much Arielle oh god this is
gonna be a long video by the way if
you're not ready to sit in here for a
while it's gonna be a lot of mail to get
through and I can't get this back in
okay and that's why I'm only reading a
part of it but I still got so much to go
through all right we got here we got
some Worf stache is the definition of
awesome I'm gonna have to do another
video with Worf staff soon because
people like the new people that coming
and don't know who that is and it's a
character in mine you know from the
Slenderman the fall of Slender Man video
oh who was that from I don't think there
was a name on there there's a signature
but I don't know the name Dana Martinez
so thank you so much Dana
all right that's another one down we got
more to go more and more more and more
and more from autumn Laci hello mark my
name is autumn I have been watching your
videos for quite a while now and there
have been so many question I've been
dying to ask you never seem to answer
them during the live stream so I thought
the only way to really get to you would
look these questions would be to ask you
through a letter so here we go do you go
to Google Lake I don't even know what
that is she lives in Ohio too so I don't
know have you ever seen or heard of this
show Impractical Jokers no I have not if
you could if you could would you own a
pet sloth I'm not to pick on pets so I
probably wouldn't and it seems like that
would be harder to take care of than
anything else I'm seeing as you know
Oney and G do you know of psychic
pebbles I probably see him one of their
videos but I'm bad with names so I don't
know the name off the top of my head do
you know jontron Danny go rapture a
rapture Raptor yes I do I love egoraptor
and I've seen a few jontron videos and
he is absolutely incredible I love him
to death
everybody knows the song do you like the
song thrift shop I like it but I don't
listen to a lot of music what's the best
90's net kurt nickelodeon cartoon to you
either dog or Rugrats I'm not sure I
watched a lot of rug
so who's your favorite youtuber to watch
Freddie Wong um thank you for reading my
weird pointless letter full of questions
keep on going with your amazing videos
your hilarious and amazing and I'm glad
I stumbled upon you well thank you so
much autumn thank you very much
yeah that's a good note not making fun
of my ability not to grow a moustache
it's not fair
oh and I hope my minecraft my microphone
doesn't sound different because it was
kind of bugging out it might be dying I
might have to get a new microphone soon
but hopefully it's not what do we have
here
there's something on here hang on
what oh there's wait which one's the
front mark you will get one from each
letter I send and there's a little
there's a little Lego Bane there I think
that is Lego Bane yeah let's see all
right thanks mark for being awesome and
cute I spend 24/7 watching your videos
and talk about you I lost some friends
because they hate you well I don't want
you to lose friends over me that makes
me feel bad but they're lost here's
things my friend and family drew from
you how do you lose friends over liking
a youtuber I'm so sorry I didn't mean
for that to happen that's totally
unintentional I'm sorry that that
happened that way sorry I'm sorry
hopefully that's an exaggeration but if
it is feel bad all right so we got one
more why mark yeah my my my my moment
way my haha Oh someone doesn't know how
to send a letter oh it's fan art ooh
that's not bad
take that out man hey dude face it's
like a picture it's oh no it's exactly
the same wait no that's not quite thank
you so much um mm-hmm hosts um Ibrahim I
think that is I'm not sure sorry I
butcher a lot of names so thank you so
much that means a lot that you thought
that this was good enough to draw all
right moving on got to keep going gotta
keep moving gotta keep moving trying to
keep this under 30 minutes ooh
I remember this one we got an actual
card here every single day do something
that makes your heart sing by Marisha
marcia wieder ooh that's pretty cool
check that out you lied to me Mario oh
good you yeah what does that say I just
watched on Farrah Mario before forum for
it while drawing this my name is Kristen
and here's some greetings from Florida I
want to say how much I admire what you
do with all your charity work both your
personality and videos always put a
smile to my face keep up the great work
take care and best wishes Kristen a
longtime fan there's a little drawing a
Kristen in the corner there with a bitty
little mustache so thank you so much
Kristen oh right
get back in there get back in there and
I'm sorry if I can't read you're a read
your letter and a lot of people were
like expecting me to write back I'm not
gonna be able to write back to nearly
anyone and let's say like an extremely
extremely big gift
so like thank you guys so for writing me
okay dearest markiplier my name is
Hula's Wiz and I'm the assistant manager
at the Pita Pit by Gonzaga University in
Spokane Washington I've been a huge fan
of yours for a while now ever since your
first Slendy videos since then you've
shown me a myriad of video games and I
never would have known about now I fully
support more independent games because
of you and your reviews I also tried to
donate as much as I can during your
charity livestreams I do agree with you
the video games can change the world for
the better especially with the work
you've been doing and I feel more people
like more people should take your
example and try to make this world a
better place through charitable
livestreams to show my gratitude for
everything that you've done for this
channel I'm enclosing this pita pit card
with enough points loaded onto it to
gift you a free pita at the nearest
location to you at 33 East High Street
in Oxford Ohio for five oh five six
which I'm sorry that it might be a bit
of a drive to routine so I got a free
pita whatever that is I don't really
know who but I got it
it says market boo it's a pita pit card
with a coupon bead app it card I don't
what is that and we're back cuz I
accidentally hit the spacebar what stop
my recording okay moving right along
hopefully this won't throw it off too
much but we're back and everything's
gonna be okay okay so thank you so much
oh I didn't even notice that there's
Slendy drawn on the envelope there
hopefully I didn't get an address in
there sorry sorry sorry if I did sorry
anyway so hey you know what second I
practiced I did it again god I can't
stop okay I'll try to I'll try to get
rid of that alright thank you thank you
so much Hula's i hope i'm pronouncing
your name correctly alright we just got
a few more here this is some fan art
alright big one - hang on whoa this is
big it's a big mustache with Slenderman
dead space amnesia and drunk minecraft
and my name up in big letters so thank
you so much that's big ever right and
there's also a letter here dear mark I
love your videos and I decide you to
draw you a quick sketch of all my
favorite Let's Plays that you have
recorded it was rushed so it isn't that
amazing sigh but I hope you still like
it
you should come visit here down here in
Louisiana it's great really it is make
sure you check maybe you could check my
deviantART account lil Abell and see
some of my photography too well he'll be
like the picture and stick it up on the
wall in your background for everyone to
see all the cool stuff you get I'm glad
you let us all send you mail and prepare
for a ton of love letters from other
fangirls PS I've always held my hand up
when you asked if Wade was a douche bag
o fan Lily what thank you you're like
the best fan now so thank you so much
Lily for sending me laughs alright
moving along just one more ah let me
hide up the address here it's got a
little dwarf stash on there so thank you
let's see what's inside a hand-drawn
letter what do Lou know dude that's
hilarious
I've never seen something like this wait
there's something here sorry man I can't
draw butts that that's really ok I don't
really care about
that but haha I got you by your shirt
giggling do you really do that's pretty
clever I like that lot so thank you so
much and here's a letter it's a long one
I'll just read uh dear mark I would like
to start this letter off by saying thank
you for doing what you're doing your
gameplay video is actually all of them
always cheer me up whenever I'm having a
bad day after school I always check up
on your channel and smite Oh smile not
smite smile whenever a new video is
posted and I don't usually react that
way to any other YouTube gamer
maybe it's because you're kind-hearted
and care for your subscribers or perhaps
your voice and looks maybe or maybe all
of the above yep all the above sounds
right but anyway anyhow your kindness
and great videos inspire me to become a
YouTube gamer myself once I get all the
tools I need I'll try doing what you do
have fun and raise money for charity and
if I ever make a big underneath tube
you'll be the first person I credit and
when I credit you whoo-hoo-hoo it's
gonna be a marvelous moment because
there will be a confetti and stuff
oozing caps I had to read it letters
don't cap well paper scraps since we
don't have any real confetti anyway I
made you a little paper child doodle to
do you can hold you by the shirt or pin
his shirt against the wall or something
and sorry it's not laminated all that
well scotch tape was the only thing I
had available so I had to make do oh and
also sorry for making him yak look like
you jumped into a pile of charcoal evany
pencils can be dirty at times again
thank you for everything and I hope you
enjoy the little gift I made you okay
negative one w-who thank you so much
this is awesome I mean I'm actually I'm
gonna hang that up somewhere I think I
will pin it to my wall so I can laughing
like oh okay thank you so much that
means a lot okay we're getting into the
bigger stuff now it starts out with just
um letters getting bigger here and
there's actually I think I think there's
a game I think someone sent me a game
I'm not sure but I will look at it in
just a moment okay I know I don't think
I've looked at this one already so this
is new to me
oops oh it's a Yoshi egg dude that's
awesome
look at that that's so cool it's it's on
melted beads and that's like
that's really cool that is a Yoshi egg
right I'm pretty sure that's a Yoshi egg
I'm pretty sure red Yoshi egg thinks so
okay there's a letter to hey Mark I am
one of the biggest fans of your videos
sometimes they even get a good scare
from them some of them anyway I was
asking if you could do me a favor this
spring or summer depends on when you get
when I get done writing it I'm going to
be shooting a movie and we're really
appreciative you could be a narrator for
it it would be amazing if you could come
if you are interested email me back at
and my address is Oh send me an email
about it I'm always interested in
projects like that I always encourage
people doing things creatively so
definitely keep trying I'm actually
gonna I really like that that's really
cool thank you so much for that all
right so um tell me an email about that
alright I'll email you I don't I'll put
this aside so I remember okay alright so
this looks like a game it's kind of
thick and there's a bit of green you can
see on the inside here I think it's a
video game so let us see oh man live
openings I'm just gonna turn my channel
into an opening channel yeah whoa
someone just gave me saints row the
third that is kinda awesome I've
actually played Saints where the third
and um while it was oh okay no they
didn't because it's actually Halo 2
that's and this is games for Windows so
this is completely wonky but ooh cool
thanks I guess I'm going to play that I
didn't even know halo 2 was on computer
yet it was a halo 3 that's coming to
computer I don't really remember cuz I
don't follow that but that's cool I've
wanted to play the halo 2 campaign for a
while so I'll give that a try and
there's something else in here what have
we got well we got a letter hi mark I'm
sending you this game because I would
like to see you take a break indie
horror game and one would like you to
try halo 2 it's in a different case
because I couldn't find the real one
mine
name is William William I'm eleven and
one live oh that's an eye you rate your
eyes funny live in Carmel Indiana not
too far from you I like your videos and
I also like to play indie horror games
and other video games just like you yes
my handwriting is terrible so my mom
wrote what I said oh that's what it's
very loopy I was like this doesn't look
like an 11-year old so and V Liam thank
you so much for the free game that's
very generous of you
I mean I will probably play it you know
I will because I wanted to play all
right put that over there oh sorry did I
just put in a dress up again I kept
doing that stop at me the unabomber is
gonna find them okay there's another one
I actually opened this one already this
is I believe fan art yes it is a whole
bunch of it too alright we got uh Yoshi
Yoshi and all a bunch of Mario stuff and
we got Spyro the Dragon I should
probably look at these make sure they're
not obscene and Batman
I like that Batman that's a nice Batman
so thank you so much for that and
there's a letter that goes with that as
well let me just get that hang on I'm
sorry I'm sorry nilly throwing things
around I'm not prepared at all for this
oh my goodness this is long okay game
suggestions and these your reins Skyward
Sword Conker's Bad Fur Day but you make
me smile when I'm feeling down I have a
special needs Brotherhood has to have
surgery soon he has to have implants but
money is a complicated issue it's about
one to twenty thousand depend on the
certain situation sometimes I feel left
out because of all the attention on him
but you helped me face a fact he is
mental he is mental and can't do things
like a normal adult he's 18 I wish I can
meet you but I know that's not a
possibility keep up the good work and be
funny like usual alright thank you very
much and thank you for all the art my
name is Lila and I have a crush on you
markiplier I know you're too old for me
and you probably have a girlfriend I'm
single but ya know so I might as well
forget about marrying you
was I not supposed to read that out loud
I don't know who's kind of already on
camera cuz
but thank you so much and sorry it
doesn't work out between us our love can
never be okay this is big did I open
this one I'm not sure I don't remember
which one of these I've already opened
oh my oh my oh my this is an essay oh
this is not an essay oh I hope you
enjoyed your day you're eight pages I
also wanted to tell you that I hope you
could be the most subscribed channel on
YouTube and please play ass ass ins
Creed 3 enjoy from Bionicle rock six two
four one and Slendy LOL i'm sorry for my
writing and writing is bad ok it's it's
the Slenderman page just don't look or
it takes you always watching no eyes
leave me alone
the plenty in the forest helped me and
can't won no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no and follow us so
thank you so much I will put these in
the forest for someone else to find
let's not govern my microphone and we
got another big one here that says open
with care cool art enclosed so let's
give it a try I've got my special
artists scalpel here that I can open
this with maybe this is sealed up really
tight so sorry if I damage it while
we're trying to get it open I'm really
not thank you do so did I just cut right
through the okay good I did not sorry
like I said I'm totally unprepared and
explicitly unprofessional it was like
I'm like totally totes mix croats not
professional right now alright let's
open this up man they really lock this
up tight I mean it's like completely
shut down here ridiculous yeah there we
go
that side is open I think I can get it
down now maybe yes there's okay well we
got here
we got a nice big letter for me to read
and that's pretty good unlike that check
out its me a dead space monster in my
shirt Slendy with a nice red dye and the
amnesia grunt who's naked very naked and
some of my slogans so thank you guys and
I have apparently I have 7 billion
subscribers so that's pretty good not
bad and let me put this scalpel away
before I cut myself all right dear
markiplier I don't write letters often
when I do it has to be for something
pretty important I don't know if you
will get the opportunity to read this
anytime soon because after all you
probably buried in fan mail right now
yes I am but if you do I'd be honored to
know you acknowledged it while I'm
reading it on air so that's pretty good
let's see um I'm not gonna make this a
gut spilling buffet bull honkey because
you get plenty of that from your
fangirls anti header anti head dro
sexual admirers what size everybody's
got problems right I will however tell
you that your potential for success of
epic proportions is very great 1 million
is totes mix Croats gonna happen you are
my favorite youtuber and always will be
there's more here there's a lot more
here but I got to get to other things so
thank you so much
Josiah Josiah Josiah Josiah a Keller
so PS you're like the real world Isaac
Clark of video games best gamer of
practically every youtuber so thank you
so much and thank you for the fanner and
it really means a lot that you guys have
done so much I mean that's incredible
okay that's all the letters now we got
to open the boxes so smallest one first
no that's my address so you're good
we're good all right smallest one first
let's get this open I could I don't even
need this scalpel yes I do I need this
couple could this be a bar of soap it's
small whatever it is it's in a box
that'll narrow it down it's small and in
a box let's see what it is
Oh God come on there we go whoo this
what could this be
I gotta find this out candle light table
lamp
huh well it's really taped up what what
is this I'm so confused
all right there's something there's
something smaller in here oh please
don't be a bomb mini bomb okay -
markiplier dear mark thanks for being
awesome i watch your videos every day
and watch your live streams when i can
thank you for caring about charity and
about your fans that set you apart from
most of or let's players I hope to you
can you continue to grow and make a
difference here's a gift for you I hope
you like it
I'm glad to make more if you want to use
them as prizes for charity or to sell in
your store let me know if you like those
ideas well let's see what it is it's a
work that necklace what I gotta put this
on hang on I gotta put I'm not used to
putting on Jory look at that it's a war
sash necklace that's so cool I mean I
probably won't wear it in public but
leave that that's so cool if I could
actually sell stuff custom stuff on this
store I would definitely encourage you
to sell these because these are amazing
maybe on Etsy or something you could
like make your own store I mean I don't
own big mustaches so you're perfectly
okay to do whatever you want
oh no is this how the secret anthrax get
into me I put this up to my nose because
they knew I was gonna put it right up on
my lips anyway so this is how I die oh
well I died well so thank you so I'm
gonna wear this for this video thank you
so much um who was that where's the name
where is the name there's no name
there's there's no name well anyway
thank you you know who you are so thank
you so much that that is an incredible
gift I'm actually getting presents this
is weird like I stopped caring about
like Christmas in my birthday a while
ago so it's so weird to be excited to
open these things all right got
something else here this is kind of a
hefty box here of send out cards find
out what's in it though so let's see oh
man
like that's getting crowded I need some
space here
okay opening ooh it's cookies it's
cookies and this and cookies it's cards
and cookies look at the cookies I got a
cookies ooh I hope they weren't I hope
this is what isn't one of them that's
been sitting in my inbox for all weekend
oh look at this look I got four packets
of cookies I'm gonna get so fat
oh I'm gonna get so fat I'm gonna get so
fat and I'm not even gonna care oh thank
you so much who was this I don't know
but it seems to it came from send out
cards so let me open this from Sarina
gore ham I think that's who it's from I
like I like I like this fan er the
person who draw this I really like their
fan art so dear markiplier
congratulations on almost two hundred
thousand subscribers well this might
have been sitting there a while oops
well by the time you get this probably
get so oh how you might already be there
you are my absolute favorite youtuber
you I've been watching you since your
videos in August of 2012 I'm so thankful
for your generosity and humor at the
time of funding finding your channel my
grandmother was diagnosed with stage 3
lung cancer and through that tough time
your videos made me laugh every single
day thank you for a wonderful
entertainment and for the smiles you
bring me every day
Sarina well thank you that means so much
and I hope your grandma is doing better
I mean that's rough stage 3 lung cancer
that's that's pretty rough to go through
so thank you guys so much for these
gifts it's incredible I mean I never
expected to get things like this okay we
got one more from Alicia Melo one of the
big supporters of my channel so let's
see what we got more cookies I'm hoping
more cookies
oh no my stack of letters won't that guy
put down on the ground there get a
little better here oh right I probably
got to plan this out beforehand I
probably get to make sure that
everything is like open that way I can
just get to it immediately
so I just I wanted to have some ceremony
with the boxes to open them who we got
fanart what is that
hashtag boobs that's a pretty good
Necromorph there it's not bad it's also
good everything else hi mark I just
wanted to say thank you for making such
great videos my mom and I would like to
congratulate you for making it to two
hundred thousand subs or
no excuse me two hundred thousand
subscribers I hope you enjoy the gifts
they are meant for partying you touch
deserve it to use your gift for future
videos peace out
got another fan out here gone oh he
loves you oh okay that's not nearly as
menacing as I thought it was gonna be
and what have we got what is this that's
a bottle girl it's a beer koozie with
boobs
you're kinda that's cool I like that I
don't actually drink bottles when I play
drunk minecraft whoo I got a shot glass
here I always like getting shot glasses
let's see what we got yeah yeah it's
pretty much true oh yeah I do me I do me
so hard I like that thank you so much we
got another mustache thing here a pink
mustache keychain ring yeah I actually
need a new keychain ring so I might it's
a little gaudy for my taste but I might
actually be persuaded to use it let's
see and a car decal I think this is geek
is the new sexy
I would agree but I'm no nerd I'm no
geek either man coach Mike scrote school
Oh two shot glasses
oh I'll out drink all you [ __ ] but
I'm a very very light drunk so that
probably won't happen
that is awesome thank you so much Alisa
that this means a lot there's a lot of
gift it's not cookies but it's just as
good now there's one more thing here I
know there's a been a long video so
there's one more thing
down here that I gotta open so sorry for
all the rambunctious miss that's been
happening how do I open this how do I
open you there no easy way to open this
doesn't look like it is alright here we
go with the scalpel go off the top one
second yeah and what are you are you a
bomb it might be a bomb I'm just reading
the packing list oh my god you guys oh
my god oh my god you guys oh yeah oh
yeah oh man there's so much tape hang on
I'm getting it I really should have
planned this out beforehand but then I
wouldn't have as much surprised when I
actually see it cuz I like being
surprised by this stuff you all probably
don't care that I'm spending too much
time opening the things
oh man it's gummy mustaches look they
smell great mmm I'm gonna get so fat if
you guys don't even know how fat I'm
gonna get look how many of them there
was that Oh
Moisture safe refrigerant pack that's
cool ice bricks
I guess well interesting so I guess you
were just meant to be temperature
control so that they didn't get too hot
they do feel kind of cool so forth look
at these they're they're gummy mustaches
that's so cool I'm gonna regret eating
them but I guess I got to eat them
before they get boiled the gummies get
spoiled I don't even know wow you guys
have been incredible thank you so much
for the gifts and the letters I mean
actually is weird cuz I feel like you
guys care is that weird to say I don't
know it just is it's really cool I mean
I never thought I'd be getting gifts
from people why why should i why but I
don't know that's just really cool so
thank you guys so much thank you
everyone this
absolutely incredible aiya I love it
everything gotten in I'm sorry I
couldn't read all the letters otherwise
I'd be here for hours but seriously
thank you guys so much it's it's an
honor to know that I'm sorry I'm popping
bubble wrap it's an honor to know that
you guys like think that highly of me to
want to make stuff for me and send me
stuff I'm still wearing the necklace and
it's just really cool so thank you guys
so much you know if you want to send me
stuff and I could probably do giveaways
with it I mean if you got something cool
like I would love to give away some of
these it would be cool I could throw in
some shirts and everything like that and
we can make a big event out of it but
either way thank you guys so much you've
been incredible I I never thought I'd be
getting stuff like this so really thank
you and I can't stop popping this okay
I'm done so seriously thank you guys so
much and um if you didn't know like
where all this came from I have a peel
box now I just released it I had a pita
box the Bo box is actually in the
description so if you want me send me
more stuff I will do another video next
Monday and maybe I'll do a regular think
about it I don't know but either way if
you guys have something for me send it
to me I'm more than happy to open it on
camera
it's something cool I will gladly open
it for you guys so thank you all so much
for everything remember check the
description for everything and just
thank you again you guys are the
greatest so I mean just thank you so
thanks for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye